all of crypto is probably a ponzi scheme
oh my gosh even i mean i really don't
want to call names here
but he pumps coins all the time
if you want to dude do it okay i'm gonna
just say one
okay real quick before you start this
interview and we're gonna talk about
everything from bit connect to the fbi
to the sec
um suing trayvon to uh hex
we're gonna talk about all of that and
i'm gonna challenge trayvon and a lot of
it let me just say up front so there's
no confusion okay this interview i
purposely went in pretty light-handed uh
i didn't want to come in shouting partly
because i don't know enough about crypto
to feel like um
i really have the platform to do that
but also partly because i wanted to hear
trayvon's own case for himself his whole
idea of coming on was
you know to have me hear him out on his
explanation so i decided to give him
that
but i wanted you know to make it clear
less that my lack
of just yelling scammer on zoom makes it
seem like i'm implicitly endorsing him
i'm not i would not trust trayvon james
with a single satoshi
of my money okay it's partly because i
from this interview i'm pretty convinced
that he doesn't know
how to spot a scam or a ponzi scheme
and he just sees things that make money
as not a scam and then as soon as it
loses money it is a scam but that's not
how
anything works it's so i i i don't trust
it that way
and also um i don't mean to put it just
on trayvon though
what i've learned after interviewing
asker fulman trayvon james and now i
also
interviewed bitboy crypto after this
interview
um i've learned that i don't think you
can really trust
anybody in the space look it's
unregulated
so let me make the coffeezilla position
on all these guys
clear because we're gonna do that
interview with bitboy crypto later you
can look out for it another sunday
do not i repeat do not
follow the advice of these crypto
youtubers
from talking to them they're all talking
about how other people have conflicts of
interest and other people
are running scams but the reality is if
everyone in the space is saying that
then it kind of tells you something
about the space look this market's
unregulated and the end of the day you
gotta watch out for numero uno these
guys aren't gonna save you when you lose
your money
and you'll find that in this interview
so yeah i wanted to have a casual
cordial conversation with trayvon but i
wanted to make it clear
my position on crypto youtube
this industry is so full of scams like
obviously there's also money to be made
i'm acknowledging that but there's so
many scams in this industry it is unlike
anything i've ever seen before
um but with that said i i hope you enjoy
should be an interesting interview let
me know what you think in the comments
below and i'll see you tomorrow
ladies and gentlemen welcome to sunday
special where we i talk to whoever i
want to okay get over it
get over yourselves we gotta do it how
we're gonna do it okay
but today we're talking to is it i
apologize apologize trayvon or
he's gonna travel my my my parents call
me travon
people call me trayvon james uh
you re i basically published a video
about the bitcoin community sort of at
the height of the
the recent uh bitcoin bull run and
uh the next day i think everything like
fell apart
so i don't know we're going back up now
uh 37k
but anyway you reached out and you said
hey um
i was inspired by this guy telling his
story about you know
how he got into crypto it's this
alluring space
he kind of did some things um he
regretted later
but you said you wanted to tell your
story yeah now
do you want to give some background as
to who you are real quick
uh for my audience who isn't from crypto
go back to like well
maybe you should tell me your intentions
of coming on and then we'll and
then we'll talk so um i watched uh
what's his name
uh oscar fulman okay i got her
i i watched this his interview and uh i
was inspired
um just because i haven't had a chance
to
vent and i i agree with a lot of things
that he said
and um there's a lot of there's a lot of
youtubers
who who do exactly what he's he does and
still do it
um and you know i want to tell my my big
connect story
you know i haven't i've never told the
story it
i have never went on any one show and
told the entire story
and i i figured what better channel to
do it than the guy who exposes scammers
yeah dude let's do it hey so for
you guys who don't know um and i only
found it at this after because i don't
follow the
the space too closely i'm not a crypt uh
big crypto guy only
recently did i really even get exposed
to much so you guys are probably gonna
notice i'm not
i'm not a genius when it comes to crypto
you're gonna have to accept that but but
i did some digging into you obviously
um prior to this interview so
travon was one of the biggest promo the
biggest maybe
promoter of the biggest don't don't try
to don't try to do that carlos
i thought it was motto no carlos was
very so you screwed over a lot of people
a lot of people left hanging the bag a
lot of people have people left with the
bag
a lot of people losing a ton of money
i'm just going to be real with you
well we're going to talk about that see
that's what we can talk about yeah we
definitely have to do it
that's that's what we should talk about
because yeah that's that's that's why
you're coming on
so uh to talk about it so but that gives
people context
even the the government got involved i
think there's some like lawsuits
associated to this with
i i don't want to be wrong here the sec
or somebody
yes gotten a lot of calls from very big
people good boys
okay okay so yeah we're gonna talk about
that
and then you said you've been trying to
clean up your brand going forward so in
the subsequent
section we'll talk about that uh but you
guys can make what you want out of it
but i want to bring people on
who you know we we can have on
trevon you told me before this i can be
as hard as i want so we're going to do
that and we're going to do it all
right let's get into it so tell me tell
me
what happened with big connect because
people you probably have the most
infamous meme of bit connect or one of
them
technically i have one of the best music
which is
everyone listen up you didn't lose your
money
now you you have your
technically you kind of lost your money
let me go let's go
back i want to give people some
backstory on me
um a lot of people there's a
misconception about me that you know i
got into crypto
through big connect and that is very
very very false
okay um i got into crypto before i got
into crypto i was looking at char i was
charting trading
doing all that stuff at least two to
three years before i even discovered
bitcoin
um around 2015 i discovered bitcoin
bitcoin was around 369
um i took about 50 bucks and
started gambling with bitcoin sites and
i turned that
fifty dollars into like a hundred and i
was like wow if i if i could do this
every day man i'm gonna be rich
and then the next day i try to double
that hundred and i lost it all
so now i had to start doing a little bit
more digging and i got
really uh i was just really amazed by
the technology of bitcoin
so after that fast for a little while
started watching a couple of youtubers
um got inspired because i had youtube
channels um before and i just do comedy
channels
i used to do dancing i used to do all
types of youtube channels
so i said i can start a channel about
crypto that aren't many crypto youtubers
it's a small niche you know maybe i can
get some traction in there
so i started making uh youtube content
just basically talking about the price
if you go back to my channel you can see
some of the old videos
where i was talking about bitcoin going
to five thousand it went way past five
thousand with the twenty thousand
um so i was just documenting the price
um then i started finding these little
uh
platforms or uh mining like bitcoin
cloud mining with genesis mining
so i started doing genesis mining i got
really
really that's where i made a killing not
so much referrals for referrals later on
but in the beginning just
from being in it so early made a killing
on genesis mining the genesis turned out
to be a scam it shut down right like in
genesis mining is still uh is still is
still going genesis mining isn't a scam
they actually have i like i was about to
say they actually flew me out to iceland
um i think that was 2016 they flew me
out to iceland
i saw their mining rigs they have a huge
facility they are
really mining crypto in us they actually
i don't think they blindfold them they
were going to blindfold me but they
didn't blindfold me
um out in the middle of nowhere in
iceland um they're really out there in
mind it's still going
so i made a killing with genesis mining
so that's enough that's a misconception
people think that i made everything
from bit connect and even you know
talking to the sec and stuff
i had to tell them like i was doing
crypto way before big connect
um big connect goes later down the road
so how much do you think you made from
genesis
ballpark me i mean
tens uh tens of of bitcoin
um which was later stolen which i got
hacked
um we'll get there um oh buddy this is
gonna be a good story okay yeah so i
mean i don't know if you want to
interrupt
and uh ask some questions in between
because i'll get through the whole thing
in like five seconds
no no no no no keep going because i
don't know that much about genesis i
can't comment too much on it okay so
genesis
um basically they mine the bitcoin and
you can basically buy these
mining contracts from them and they can
you basically rent their miners
their i understand the concept like the
cloud the cloud
thing i just don't know too much about
like
you know how profitable that is how not
oh yeah it's not profitable it is i mean
it was it was profitable
back then but now they've they've kind
of fallen falling a little bit because
it's not people aren't going for it it's
not it's not profitable anymore cloud
mining is not profitable so if anybody
out there if anybody ever tells you to
get in cloud mining don't do it
you're better off just buying the
bitcoin you know so after that
what happened um after genesis mining
um that's when i started to
i found big connect um a friend of
a fellow youtuber um i'll call him a
friend
craig grant i don't know if you heard
about him he was doing youtube videos
he actually discovered big connect and
started doing videos about big connect
first
and then that inspired me to get into it
and then i started
and that that's that's where that's
where it started
he found it um it was a really small
crypto
at the time and started doing videos
and just kept making videos that's
basically how it started
sure sure sure and so you start picking
it up on it
you start making videos um
now for those of you who don't know big
connect
um is called by many to be a ponzi
scheme would you agree with that
um here's the thing this is the this is
another
common uh misconception with bit connect
we still don't know if it was legit or
not
now i know that sounds crazy but you
have to one thing you have to consider
is
big connect was working people were
making crypto
every single day and loving it and then
texas stepped in i think it was texas
first and said hey
cease and desist and then that started a
a snowball effect of other states
saying cease and desist so they
ultimately gave all the coins back and
that's where
that's where the scam kind of comes in
where it's like
hey we want to give us our bitcoin back
but they gave everybody their big
connect coins back because you remember
you
you were locking up the big connect
coins to earn i'll say that
to earn interest on them so people
wanted their bitcoin back they gave them
their big connect coins back
wait don't you mean they're locking up
their bitcoin to get bitconnect coins
yeah man it's been so long i can't even
really remember how but i but i
but big connect for everyone who doesn't
know was promising i think one percent
steady
returns right per day i know i'm going
to sound like i'm defending bitcoin a
lot but there are a lot of
misconceptions there were days where we
didn't get
any interest sure sure but but they were
privacy crazy returns they were
promising
they were promising interest yes right
and so the question is
where were where were they getting that
money from and the
that's what makes a ponzi scheme is it
requires people to keep putting money in
in order to pay out the other people and
so of course a ponzi scheme
i would call it yeah i would call it a
ponzi scheme but my
my problem is that
it was going good like i would i would
even argue the fact that
a lot of critical people are going to
hate from just saying this but all of
crypto
is probably a ponzi scheme oh my gosh
even i mean now i know i say hold on a
second i know it sounds bad
but we have to break down what a ponzi
is upon oh we get with a upon we know
what a ponzi is
but ponzi is a person it's charles ponzi
it's named after a person so
a ponzi is actually a just a a way of
moving money around so it's not
something that could
it's not an evil thing unless you use it
as an easy
way but but it but it's a type of fraud
because it has to collapse
so so it's a type of business model that
has to collapse
reason it's named after charles ponzi is
because he he
was selling these like postage stamps
and he said he was doing some arbitrage
with postage stamps he wasn't
so that's a big classic thing of ponzi's
they say they're making things money
what he said yeah but that's true like
most ponzi schemes they have an
explanation
but what they say they're gonna give you
is these super inflated returns that are
impossible
and the way they pay you those returns
and the reason it looks like it's
working
at first is because they're just paying
you with new investors and everyone's
getting involved because of course
everyone's making tons of money at first
but then
when the bottom falls out everybody gets
screwed
except for basically the initial
investors and the guy who ran
the the ponzi scheme so most people get
hurt
and then a small number of people profit
a lot and then there's the founder who
makes a ton of money
so with that being said and let me
clarify i don't want the crypto i want
to finish what i'm saying about
crypto being a policy i'm going to use
to use bitcoin as the example bitcoin
needs dollars going into it to
for the price to go up that's just
simplest that's just the simplest way
i'm going to put it
bitcoin needs money going into it for
the value of it to go up
and but it doesn't produce a uh
interest or a return but a lot of these
projects
in crypto are ponzi schemes
i mean it's just money coming in and
then when people stop buying it the
price goes down
and that's how you get these you get
these small cryptocurrencies that pump
up really high
and then they fizzle out and then they
just can't pump it in because
money no more money will come into them
that's what i mean by that so i'm sure
most crypto if
most og crypto heads will agree with me
on that it's not saying it's a bad thing
as far as the bitcoin part goes
but for the smaller projects well well
hang on because currencies
are not ponzi schemes because they don't
promise returns
the way something's upon a ponzi it
can't be a ponzi scheme
unless they say hey you're going to get
this much they're promising these wild
returns
and then they're they're funding those
returns they're funding payouts
so maybe ponzi is a bad word for it but
basically if
money stops coming into bitcoin it will
stop going up in price
right and that's true and that's true of
all currencies is that if they're if you
lose faith in the currencies
no no no no no no no no
is a ponzi scheme because they were
promising people insane returns
bitcoin inherently now there are people
who are pumping
like crypto like as if it's a ponzi by
saying oh you're going to get these
insane returns whatever
but uh these these things are not
inherently ponzi schemes because you
don't have that business model set
in the framework bitconnect had that in
the framework they said give
us bitcoin and we'll give you back this
thing at this crazy rate of return right
so then when it started falling apart
they
they just left left everyone else
holding worthless crypto that no one
wanted because they
right right because texas just sent a
season but it was because of the
government it was the government's fault
but wait wait but if texas hadn't
intervened
more people would have gotten hurt do
you see what i'm saying because ponzi's
have to fall apart
because in order for them to pay people
you have to you need more and more
people at the bottom but eventually you
run out of people to get into your
scheme because you have too many
like eventually like you're right about
i never looked at it that way yeah more
people probably would have got hurt i
guess they stopped people from getting
hurt
i guess they had to hurt you know yeah
they shut it early so then the people
who probably would have maybe gone up
but then there are
more people at the bottom like being on
on a ship and they're like man
everybody's gotta die this but it's
gonna save you know millions of lives
right but that being said it was a scam
though or do you agree with that i i
want to make sure that you
get i'm gonna go ahead and say they
probably didn't have trading back i'm
gonna go ahead and say that they
probably didn't have a trading bot
all right right they hit yeah right um
okay so then go ahead so where
where was i in the story um so you were
saying
oh yeah so i found big connect yeah
right that's where i was so i'm gonna
finish start
keep going from there yeah yeah yeah so
you found big connect
you started hyping it up right hyping it
up
um i don't think i wouldn't say
hyping it up my thing is a youtuber and
well as of now i don't i don't hyped up
things but maybe back then i might have
been hyping it up
i was doing it um and telling people how
great it was going
how great it was going so um i guess i
guess that's hyping it up
uh showing my experiences with it um i
started with about
a hundred bucks man i put a hundred
bucks in it
and then i made like this um you know
and
another thing people call me a scammer
and it's like
no man because i wasn't out to hurt
people
um everyone that was involved in this
was doing great so it wasn't that i was
harming i wasn't intentionally harming
anyone so i set these facebook groups
and was showing people like um how to
market it and stuff like that
didn't really the facebook group didn't
really get that big i wasn't really big
on it but that's how i kind of started
it
you know um click my link
uh i'll add you to this facebook group
and that was kind of incentive to join
under me and once i started kind of got
that snowball rolling
you know it was the first time i ever
like was successful at a
a mlm or referral um type program and it
was
incredible to watch the just to watch it
grow and grow and grow and grow
um so yeah i started with 100 bucks i
started doing videos and
and one morning i remember waking up and
i had like you know a couple
thousand dollars you know keep in mind
like i wasn't really
even after genesis now with genesis you
got to remember bitcoin was cheap
back then so when i say ten tens of
bitcoin it might sound like a lot now
but back then you know bitcoin was maybe
like a thousand bucks so i mean like ten
thousand dollars you know it's not that
much
back then so to wake up one morning and
have made
almost as much as i made the entire time
in genesis
was like whoa okay this is about to get
crazy
and i just i just kept showing my
results like i wasn't really at that
point
i wasn't really telling people to get
into it it was just more of whoa
i woke up this morning i'm live
streaming it's how much i have in my big
connect wallet
uh this is how much i made today and
then i'll do it again the next one i
just kept doing that and i guess the
whole transparency of me
showing uh how much i'm making that's
what
really hyped it up um you know when i
got to like
um well i mean i think it was a little
bit more than you just showing i mean
you were telling people you got to get
into big connect
and and you used your your profits as
proof
of why they should get in but you're
telling everybody to get in with you
right
um but yeah of course i want people i
wanted people to make
money like it's not like i was expecting
anything to go wrong see people that's
the that's the thing you got to think
about in the moment in the moment this
is great
it's working i mean what you want me to
say it's bad now one thing i wish i
would have done
if i now people ask me if you could if
you could go back would you do it again
would you not get in big connect
i would do everything the exact same way
but what i would do this time around
is i will tell people to be a lot more
careful knowing what i know now
i would tell people because i wasn't i
had really never gotten into anything
that was really bad before so i wasn't
expecting anything to go wrong
i got into crypto at the bottom in 2015
when bitcoin was 300
everything's going up everything that i
get into everything i touch turns to
gold so why would this
be any different so the one thing i wish
i would have done is i would have wish i
would have told people
to be more careful and do your own
research and that's what i definitely
say now
i definitely tell people i'm way more
cautious
when i'm talking about crypto these days
like because i've seen a bear market
i've seen
so many scams it's most likely a scam if
it's
if it's crypto it's most likely going to
go down in value
um but now and now everything's moving
though but not yeah yeah not okay
hold on though hold on hold on hold on i
just want to clarify
a scam is not when something goes down
and then it's great if it goes up
because then things could i
be not a scam and then suddenly turn
into a scam the business model itself
can just be bad it's a bad business yeah
yeah real
fast now a scam to me is something
that's intentionally
out to rip people off that's what a scam
is to me
there is now yeah i said scam now
scam is different from a failed project
so but there are still a lot of scams in
grip though
there are a lot of projects that are
intentionally out to hey
this is something but we're really not
doing it but i think what you're saying
is you you were new to crypto you're
hyping it up
you were marketing it but you're saying
basically you didn't know
you didn't know it was a scam no i
didn't know it was a scam
um i knew there were risks you know in
the big connect
token going down but i didn't think that
you know
there was a risk and then i mean all i
saw the entire time i was being
connected as it going up it went up the
entire time until the very end
now do you feel any um
because it's interesting because you're
saying okay i didn't know it was a scam
it turned out to be a scam
basically how much fault do i hold and
actually i'm actually curious how much
fault do you think you hold for all the
people who lost
you know a life savings i'm sure tens of
thousands
i'm at fault to a certain extent because
even myself
and i'm going to get to some of these
youtubers even myself i go into things
because someone else went into it when a
youtuber like this is and this is what
inspired me to come on here
because a lot of what that that
youtubers
um said is true a lot of these guys
are getting pumping coins and wrecking
people
and saying oh this is you know this is
for entertainment this is finance this
is not financial advice they're just
saying that to cover their ass but
really
they're like yeah you know come on come
on
they know what they're doing oh they're
hyping it up yeah they know they're
hacking up there they're really trying
to get people to pump
pump the coin but they're covering their
asses if i can curse they're covering
their assets by
you know saying this isn't financial
advice um
so i forgot where i was going with that
but yeah
no i think that i think that's really
interesting i mean do you have an
experience you don't have to name names
here
where a crypto youtuber purposely
pumped a coin i know you're being like
yeah this is why i wanted to go
this is why i was so inspired all of
then sold it off like right when they
pump it man
i really don't want to call names here
but if you want to dude do it
i don't i don't really want to because i
don't want to sound like i'm hating but
a lot of these guys are starting to okay
i'm gonna just say one
then this is because i only this because
i had experience
bit boy crypto he pumps coins
all the time all of these coins now some
of them do well
i'll give him that some of them do well
but the one that i said you know what
i don't watch big boy crypto but i'm
gonna subscribe to him today and i'm
gonna go buy the coin that he talks
about today
i went and bought this coin called
ethies and i haven't checked them in a
while so
it might be up but i bought that thing
it pumped right right after this video
published
and ever since it went down and i said
man
this is not cool you know what i'm
saying i it was the first time that i
actually
went to a youtuber and was like i'm
gonna just
i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna just take this
ass i'm gonna do what most people are
gonna do
which is buy this [ __ ] because i don't i
don't chase coins and chase pumps and
stuff like that i'm
way past that if you watch my channel
you'll you'll hear me say hey bitcoin
ethereum
if you're you're most likely if you're
in anything
look at the chart versus bitcoin look at
it versus ethereum and it's most likely
been going down versus both of those the
entire time so you're better off just
holding bitcoin in ethereum
and this coin did exactly that so all of
these youtubers
all of these crypto influencers are
influencing people to get wrecked
if you get your followers wrecked
they're gonna stop following you
you know what i'm saying so you know you
know what's interesting about the bit
boy krypto thing
oh you you seen him before no i no no
i hadn't seen him before a few days ago
i'm interviewing him
tomorrow oh it's interesting yeah he
reached out to he reached out to me
after that interview
and he was like hey man wanna come on
what should i know about that guy
i don't really know about him i just
know that
he's he's gets into projects okay
so this is what happens they have these
telegram channels they have the existor
discord groups there are these things
called pre-sales in crypto
um the pre-sale will have a funding
round they have a seed round
a private seat a private round um all
these early rounds
and um they'll get some people to invest
and then they'll say all right we're
going to start marketing after they
release the coins
the price goes up a little bit and they
say all right we're going to start
marketing
we're going to hire some youtubers they
go out and they reach out to youtubers
bitboy crypto
um elio trades all these
popular [ __ ] going youtubers they reach
out to them
and then they start chattering all right
guys
big boy is going to do a video this day
he's going to do a video on this day
right here oh the video is going to be
uploaded
and all that time the price is running
up and then he publishes the video and
the price
shoots up and then all those people that
didn't weren't in the pre-sale
uh that they buy into it and then all
the people that were in the pre-sale
they dumped the price on all of those
youtube
fans they sell they sell to them
they sell the coin to them and that's
and now and now all those youtube people
that watch this video
are holding bags of these coins that
might pump one day but you're holding
the bag you're
that's uh opportunity cost you could be
in something you could be holding eath
while it's going up you could be in
bitcoin while it's going up
so they're wrecking people now
i don't and and they're getting paid
to wreck people now that's the only
thing that's what i don't understand
you know you know as i was just okay so
i've just been researching more into
crypto because the community's kind of
been talking about crypto crypto's been
on everyone's mind
yeah you know i tell people i've
encountered i i mean i
i basically look at scams all day long
it's like basically what i do now
yeah i love your channel bro so check
this out
so i've seen a lot of communities and
there's like different percentages
of how much it's a scam i've never seen
a community
with so many scams
why why is crypto so uniquely poised for
scams
it's easy um especially with the
especially with d5 right now on ethereum
i myself i've never done this i
can go make a erc20 token a ethereum
token
uh pair it with a little bit of eth 5050
put it on uni swap give it a pretty logo
and go reach out to all my buddies and
say hey this is the next big thing and
have no plan
have a pretty website nice graphics
you know a little white paper that
sounds like white paper nice graphics
you know
nice futuristic graphics start getting
some people to pump the coin price
starts going up and as the price goes
starts going up the reason the price
goes up
as far as uni swap that each
that people are putting into uni swap
makes the price go up
but there's more eth going into uni swap
as well as
less coins than uni swap right because
you paired it with 50 50.
what happens then is a thing called a
rug where they just
take all that eath the person that
provided the liquidity because they're
providing liquidity
they have that they have that ease now
they can just
take all that eth out and just be gone
so it's very
that's why so many scams because it's so
easy to launch
one um so you really got to do your own
research
and make sure you're in something legit
anonymous teams
just go ahead and say no no that's a
no-no if it's an anonymous team just
don't even mess with it if they don't
show that they don't show their faces
uh maybe i get why you know the
regulation is kind of uh
up in the air as far as you know
regulation goes so maybe they want to be
anonymous but you know for me if it's
anonymous
or if it's not by some you know a circle
of people that i'm kind of familiar with
in crypto i'm just not gonna even mess
with it
okay so we talked about how there's all
these scams being run
okay um
what have you done in crypto have you
taken some
some deals under the table oh as far as
sponsorships
yeah very very rarely
the most i did it was in the bear run
with um dapps
um a lot of stuff i
i did sponsorships with did well
but over the long run they didn't do
well i haven't done a sponsorship
i mean i might have done a total of like
five of them my entire time in crypto i
might do like five of them
and i don't ever feel good when i do it
so i don't
i mean i started saying why you but why
do it though
why do it if you don't feel good because
if you don't feel that good that's a
symbol
symptom of yeah i mean that you
shouldn't do it i don't feel good
when things go bad like the things like
i won't do a sponsorship
unless i think that it's good but i
haven't done
i don't i don't i don't do them you know
what i'm saying i the last time i i do
them with people that i know
like they're a circle of of developers
that i know and they're like hey man
i'll sell you some coins you just do a
do a video i'll do them on my depth
channel my dab channel is like the most
risky uh that's the way i do the most
risky stuff and the people that are on
there
it's a small group of people um who are
who know what's up like all of the
people in my membership
they know what's up but i always say
do your own research this is very risky
you're probably going to lose your money
you know what i'm saying so
but yeah i haven't done an uh a
sponsorship in a long time
and i'm not doing them at this like oh
i'm not doing them at the scale of what
bit boy is doing like
this guy's getting paid that i mean
i won't be surprised he's getting like
20 000 for a sponsorship video
i'll never get that that much you know
said i never do it
on a grand scale like that for me it's
like most a lot of the time people say
i'm like nah man i don't need to worry
about it i just do a video on it i don't
ever
you know if i want to do it i'll i'll
just do it without the pay you know what
i'm saying
i'm not doing it on the scale like i
even know this guy's got a course it's
like ten thousand i don't even know how
i know tech has a course that's like ten
thousand dollars if you got ten thousand
dollars to get ivan on tech
you don't need just do your own you know
saying
you're not you don't even need to know
what he's he's you know saying you can
he's not going to teach you any if you
if you're you're already rich if you can
give ivano
but here's but here's the thing i'm
hearing from like
and in the picture that i'm getting of
the crypto community
it's that there's like people at the top
that are in in the know which are
basically that
honestly if you're the smart if you
really want to sk like i would say scam
people
but also make the most money developer
then underneath that
and then like kind of near that is like
if you're a youtuber in crypto
because you make profits on both where
you're like making money from pumping
these things you're making money from
sponsorships
you're making money from having access
to these uh you know these
seed rounds that maybe nobody else has
access to these initial coin
coin funding grounds and then all the
way up about way down at the bottom
of opportunity and most of the people
who end up holding the bag
are the people who are trusting these
two
yeah which are like that's the sucky
thing to me and then
of course you can always say well didn't
you do your own research it's like no
you're the youtuber whose job it is to
do the research and then like people
like that's one reason that's another
reason why
i don't like i don't like doing i don't
like looking into this these shitty ass
projects to see if they're even legit or
not
i don't like doing that you know saying
i don't do
like i know it sounds like but it's been
so long since i've done
like uh a sponsored you know what i'm
saying and i i was and you i'll say even
this is sponsored man
so i like the the last couple that i did
man they were they were so funny because
i was like yo
this is a sponsor man so this is come on
man like let's get real like i don't
know what the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is man like
i keep it so real these days like
i'm not sugar coating but i'm just
i don't know maybe i'm just hating but
i'm hating on how like
the morality like to to to do something
the the moment that i see something go
extreme
extremely wrong after a sponsor post i
wouldn't do it anymore
like how do you pump a coin it loses so
much value
and all you you your fans are holding
backs and then
the next day you do another one like i
don't see how they're doing it man
i don't see and i don't see how they're
there that people are letting them get
away with it like
people so hard on me but everything like
one rug one rug which was big connection
one of the biggest rugs oh man
there go they're gonna be some big rugs
man when the when the market
as the liquidity and stuff on you swap
grows
the rugs are just gonna get they're
gonna they're they're already bigger now
can i can i tell you i think you get a
lot of hate why
i think it's because of uh i think your
attitude was very much
like it's not my fault you guys should
have just done yeah i wish yeah i wish i
would have been
more humble i wish i would that's like
like
when i like i say i i a few there's a
few things i wish i could have changed
one is i wish i would have told people
to do more research and let them know
how risky crypto is but i didn't
really know how risky crypto was because
i
yeah i feel like you were a beginner at
that time
advising a bunch of other beginners
basically because you only had it
when things are going well right who
hadn't been through when things are bad
right okay so with uh
so now so now you're like what's your
new so you said you're trying to rebrand
i think in
your message to me maybe or something
something to that extent
uh and that's the sort of get away from
that
trayvon is that what you're saying kind
of no i'm not changing my name
that's one thing that that people oh not
from the name i mean from like that like
that like uh what do you call it
stereotype or that that yeah
um yeah i mean i'm not really trying to
rebrand i'm just
being more realistic being that i've
been through an entire bear run in
crypto
i see how most things don't go well
um and i'm definitely telling my
followers
um most likely you're better off just
holding bitcoin and ethereum
even ethereum i would say you know it's
gonna probably produce more gains but
you
you the goal is probably
to stack bitcoin people um
show me these coins every day on my live
streams and it always comes down to
you know if it's down a lot maybe get
you some
but if it's going up you miss the ball
like it's those type of
you know those type of little lessons
that i've learned
that i'm i'm trying to teach new people
instead of you know it's going great
it's going great it's going great
you know because it's going it's going
to go great but it's going to go bad so
you know rebrand i'm not really
rebranding i'm just uh growth
i would say it's growth okay so one
question i want to ask you
is that you know obviously the big
connect fallout happens
but the story doesn't end though because
obviously
all these articles come out but more
than that this is one of the few
cryptos that you know falls apart that
really the government comes after
so you got contacted by a lot of these
feds
what what tell me the story there what
happened think about it to think
to look back so the first time i got
contacted i was in my little
apartment um that i think it was the
fbi they were knocking on my door
and i didn't answer the door they were
like javon we just want to talk we just
want to talk to you
i just was in there quiet as hell boy he
was in there so
i'm like yo this [ __ ] getting real so
then they called me
um i kind of like i don't want to say i
ran but i kind of like we went to like a
we went and stayed at a hotel for like
my son's
birthday or something like that for a
couple of days um
and they called me i'm not sure if they
called craig grant first but somehow he
gave me their number and they i
talked to them and i had a long
conversation with them
um and they were talking about my stolen
bitcoin the fbi
wanted to talk about my stolen bitcoin
so i got a whole nother stories
i got hacked for 111 bitcoin bitcoins
maybe about seven thousand dollars
i got hacked for a 111 on bitcoin
a lot of people think i faked it but the
fbi and them they know for sure
that that [ __ ] is gone so i got hacked
for 111 bitcoin
and that's what they talked to me about
and they talked about baking up a little
bit
and then after that wait hold on hold on
that's three million dollars
right now don't remind me
111 bitcoin
how and i was on a live stream i was on
instagram live stream at the time
and i think what happened is they took
my uh
they did a sim swap where they get my my
my they got my name and stuff and they
got my phone number
and they called my cell company and
acted like they were
me and got my sim swap and then they
went into my
two factor and they got into my email
which was really new with me to have my
private keys
in my email so don't ever do that don't
ever keep your private keys especially
if you're a high profile person don't
keep your private keys in the email
address
um i had them saved in drafts they went
in there took all my crypto about my
wallets
live on live stream i just was and at
the time i just was like damn
because i was bitconnect was still going
so i was like i'll make it back in
that's
that's like 90 days worth of big connect
you know i'll get i'll get it back
um so yeah i got a hack for that then
um like so the fbi called me about that
and then
uh the sec um they reached out to me and
i also got served
at the hotel by the state scc
can i just say something real quick for
anyone who has two-factor authentication
hold that thought right there nobody who
has two-factor authentication
who's high-profile should be relying on
their cell phone number to be their
second factor authentication because
everyone just does sim swaps now i mean
i wouldn't even really recommend you
need a physical
key you need a physical security key
and if you don't have one get one even
honestly if you're just like a normie
with like some money
yeah never usually use hard work and
don't use ledger use treasure
ledger always has data breaches so
you're gonna get death threats and stuff
from people that have your address and
they're gonna act like they're outside
your house
oh that's why i yeah i don't know all
the i see that's how much i'm not in
this world like i don't know the crazy
yeah okay so don't ever if anybody ever
i mean
i don't i'm never mind i'm just gonna
say if somebody ever threatens your life
for crypto i'm gonna say it's probably a
fake but it might be real sorry
um so the sec uh they reached out to me
and we're going back and forth and then
they want me to you know
settle and i didn't even get a lawyer
like
uh i got a lawyer for my state case and
then when i went to
i went to the state to have my testimony
and i realized how little my lawyer did
i was like man i probably didn't even
need that guy
that was a waste of money so then the
sec the federal sec
they started reaching out to me after
that i went they gave me a subpoena to
come testify
in new york right beside the world trade
center
this is like the real thing i went in
there by myself
testified and then they started asking
me they asked me questions a lot of
people think i stitched on people i
didn't snitch on anybody i didn't
i didn't know anything to any to even
snitch on
um so i told them the story but you have
be honest be honest if you were facing
let's say you're like six nine you're
facing like 20 to life
and you know some people that you could
snitch on to get out
yeah yeah i'm
i'm not without like a rapper i'm
telling
okay i was just asking just this
hypothetical yeah
uh yeah i'm telling for sure um so i
went up there
you know telling the story and they
started getting into like they started
playing my videos in front of me
and i went ahead and had and had to
throw that fifth in there i had to play
the fifth and then
they sent me home they sent me home and
then they started talking about settling
and they were trying to get me for some
securities law from
19 some law from 1940 something man
probably
1940s i shouldn't honestly be laughing
because it's such a serious topic
but i can't get the 110 bitcoin out of
my head so then like
i can't and i mean that's like i i i'm
like i don't have it you know they
they're they're wanting me to settle for
like this huge amount i'm like guys
i don't know who just like y'all think i
am but i don't have that man
um so i haven't really heard anything
back did you did
how much money did you lose when
bitconnect crashed did i
lose i mean i had 700 000
in loans i don't know how much i mean
i don't even remember man i got my coins
back and they were instantly like
worthless and i even bought i you
totally see that i bought these things
on the way down man
like i was so convinced man i'm like man
this thing is they they they got
something because i was talking to
um glenn the guy who was actually above
me
and he was like um i'm not sure if he
was saying don't
sell or or or just hold him or something
like that
but he had you know he had he had me in
the in the palm of his hand like he was
like nah man we're it's gonna be good
man you know don't worry about it
and no i'm going to think never probably
telling you to have all my coins
no how much do you how if it was worth
the max
price how much would that be worth if in
coins it's like
connect coins now okay so i say i say
that these big connect coins the bitcoin
coins that i have are worth a lot
because i own them
so that makes them more special so i'm
gonna hold on to them they're like a
they're like um
beanie babies you just can't sell them
right now that's right
i wish i i was away there will be a way
to sell them one day escrow
so with all that like kind of like wider
context
i do have to really uh grill you on
something
what's up with the hacks you're pitching
hacks like it's nobody's business oh
not really a bunch of videos about hacks
how many videos did you see about
hex like probably four or five maybe
i don't know i did on my main i mean
well first off hex is up like that's a
that's a
that is a scam bro come on that's just
it's not a scam i mean it might be
it might be you know and i will say that
even
go i will after this after this is over
i will send you my first
video that i did on x and it's probably
the one with the most views and since
then it's went up
[ __ ] time what i like about hex
is i know who i can point the finger at
we all know who it is that's my that's
and
that's the hilarious thing about it i
mean i treated it like a
comedy thing you know like richard hart
at least with bitconnect with bitconnect
we didn't know who
is that his real name richard hart i
don't think so i think his name his last
name is something else
i don't think people know his last name
um
so who can you point the finger out well
i think i mean
hex so so
this is my one this is my one problem
because okay okay let me
actually let me just ask you since since
i know
but i want to know what you why do you
think hex is a scam
okay so this is why i think hex is a
scam um
and let me preface this by saying this
is the thing
that i think uh this is my real bone to
pick with you because i can
i can understand how you can get into
bit connect and sort of be
sort of naive you push it really hard
you get this huge blowback you kind of
fight back against it it's not doesn't
make it right doesn't make the losses
right
but if you learn from that and then like
really got
diligent with not pitching another scam
that's like i get that
i get the arc i get the character arc
basically and you can really make the
argument like hey man
this is that was a big mistake that i
made
the but i see i see pitching hex and
then that like story becomes harder for
me to believe
and it makes me well it makes me think
like i'm not like
i haven't talked i haven't did a video
on hex since it went up
i stopped talking about it because it's
up so much like people only time i talk
about it's on my live stream people ask
about it
i never say hey man you guys should look
in the x man hex is doing real good
you guys should buy some hecks i'll
never do that you're watching old videos
that the price is higher but you still
haven't told me right
right right right right i'll explain i
explain no no that's what i'm saying i
think that's what the disconnect is
is i think for you for like the story
that i'm hearing is that like
if it's up it's not a scam but
that has nothing to do with whether it's
up hex is going to co like it will
eventually die
and alex what do you think though so
okay so
richard hart right built into hex
is him getting a 45 stake of hex
built into it is this origin address
which he says
no we don't know who has it hey well we
know
we know that he's saying that but we
know he has it right in these videos we
know he has
i will say in the videos i will say we
know
like he's saying that he's not the
original address
he's got so he's got right he's got 45
he's got 45 of the hacks he's got any
time you have a penalty so you put
withdraw your stake early and this is
going to
it's going to go over some people's
heads but when you draw your stake early
the penalty
what is it like half of it goes to the
at the origin address too so then he
gets half of that
goes to the origin address yeah and then
some of it goes to the yeah the payout
but then what about what about all that
eth everybody's staking
hey are we just trusting are we trusting
the kind
heart of richard that's not what it is
and i will say that
in the video now here's now let me tell
you what now this is what i think
and i've i've talked about x today like
i'm not liking what's going on with hex
i'm i said that today in my live stream
like
i know it's kind of it's kind of hard to
be cool with this
but you kind of have to keep up with the
story
you know what i'm saying like i might
feel one way about something one way
one day and then feel a different way
about the next now the thing with hex is
he hasn't sold
one hex from one of those origin
addresses so i gotta give him that he
hasn't sold one coin
now another thing the reason he has all
as far as what i can see the reason he
has all those coins is to have
a high market cap also it's easier
to pump the price when the way he has it
set up on liquidity
so all of that stuff it it kind of like
makes the project do what it's been
doing which is
go up a [ __ ] ton in price now i get what
you're saying about
that represents more investments doesn't
mean it's a scam i get what you're
saying there
and also you know we don't nothing's a
scam until it's a scam until it's gone
you know what i'm saying so no no no
wait wait
wait wait but but that's what that's
that's what i'm saying i'm saying
so many things in crypto are scams so
whose job is it
to filter out the noise from the signal
the good from the bad
you might say it's the individual crypto
crypto investor they have to figure out
everything that's what i think it is i
think it's the influencers
so you gotta know before you pump a coin
not the ongoing story of whether it's
turned into a scam yesterday or today
but is it going to turn into a scam how
likely is it to turn into a scam
i would say 65 days down the road i i
know it's gonna it's gonna sound crazy
but i'm gonna say it's not likely that
hex is a scam man okay
i know it sounds crazy but the because i
followed it so
so much since the beginning since i mean
since before he even launched it i've
been following i've been following
richard hart for
years i've been watching him talk and
stuff so i've i've been following him
for a long time so
i would say it's more likely that it's
not a scam and it's going to keep going
up in price because of the way that it's
designed because the way the liquidity
pool and stuff is set up
so when i got into hex it was really
really cheap
and it's gone up a lot now me
and i saw how it worked and understood
how it worked because i had been doing
d5
before then and i understood what
how massively the potential was on it
and it had
and it's pumped a [ __ ] ton since then
now is the scam
i don't know it probably isn't well
let's no no no
no let's look at the interests of
richard hart because the
like there's very few people say there's
a lot of people saying it is a scam
very few people who aren't one of them
is obviously richard hart he's their
biggest spokesman
but all you have to think about is would
richard hart be shilling this coin if it
wasn't his coin
hell no because he would do
look he's criticized several times when
other founders
take huge cuts of their own coin and
then what does he do when he starts a
coin so he would have criticized that if
it had been somebody else's coin and
what does he do
he gives himself a 45 stake that's
ridiculous then think about this
let's say you got all this like all this
eat steak right and a lot of it's coming
due
so all of a sudden he's got to send out
a ton of money right now he's got the
eth and he's got the hacks and he can
sell that whenever he wants
so he's happy but what i'm thinking
is that let's say you're richard hart
you know maybe you're looking for a
little
little exit you could try to keep this
coin
speculative going forever and then give
all these people back their eif
or what does he have like several
million dollars just people
gave him in ethereum he just decides hey
no i'm actually going to take it
all right here's the thing what's to
stop him from doing can't for one
rich your heart is already rich do you
agree with that do you think he's rich
already
rich people always want to get way
richer yeah i'm just
let me actually answer that question
though sure i i don't know but
already right yeah okay there's only
about
a million dollars in liquidity on uni
swap so if he was going to just
sell all that hex and exit he wouldn't
walk away with like a couple million
dollars
so it wouldn't even be worth the the
scam you know what i'm saying
so what if he walked away with all the
ethereum he's been using that to pump
the price like i mean he could but i
mean
well how much money when you walk away
from what i'm from what i hear
if you go watch some of richard hart's
early videos and what you'll see
is someone who i know is gonna sound
cheesy but someone who kind of wants to
help the world like he does like
he was doing videos that weren't getting
any views
talking about how to help yourself why
you should stop playing video games
why you should stop gambling stop
trading like he's been trying to help
the world he's
he's broke written books about how to
like you know live a better life so
i'm just i don't know man i i've always
given from the beginning of when i got
into x
i've always given both sides it might be
it might go really bad but if it does at
least we know it's richard hart
and it might be he's trying to create an
epic name for himself and make one of
the highest appreciating assets of all
time
you know i'm saying like i got that
based on based on a one-year track
record
i mean that's nothing during no i mean
during a one-year track record when he's
giving away most of the currency
i mean yeah hacks is what i'm talking
about i mean i'm somebody you talking
about
record of hex yeah i mean well you were
saying like like one of the best
asset track records of all time i'm
saying he's one that's what he wants to
create
but what i'm saying is the reason his
asset has pumped so much is because
it's the first year and he's basically
giving away most of the currency
after this so much because there's not
much liquidity and he's using the if to
pump the price
that's why it's pumped so much and
people are buying it and they're staking
like it's a lot of mechanics that as you
as someone who's
not really into how how the contracts
work
don't understand the reason it's pumping
is because people are locking up the hex
and staking it for 15 years and he has
this [ __ ] ton of hex that he's just not
even touching
so it's making the price go up you know
saying it's really he's
he's really giving everybody free you're
right he's giving everybody free gains
because he could just just take the
liquidity and just take everything
but he's using it to pump it's obviously
him that's pumping the price
because he's obviously one of the
genesis whales of ethereum so he's the
one that's
ever been a good idea but when has it
ever been a good idea
to invest your money with some uh
relatively unknown guy with zero
accountability
and zero recourse what are you going to
do if he runs away you said like we know
who did it okay so what you what
did it
anybody buy hex i haven't suggested i
mean i haven't suggested anyone buy
hacks since before the big payday
that's the last time i was like man i'm
buying i don't even know i wouldn't even
suggest i was talking about what i was
doing buying hacks before the big payday
to get that big payout
and since then i've just kind of laid
off of it you know like
now let's let's see what you're saying
you removed a lot of the liquidity of
yourself
you may have pumped a fraud only a few
times so what's the big deal and i'm
saying
that's your job not to pump frauds
though no i mean i'm not but it's
i don't like i i don't i don't know if
it's a fraud you say i'm saying like
it's i don't think it's a scam man i
think it's
i think it might be something great i
think people are just hating
like from the beginning people were just
hating on it from the beginning
i just think that it's i don't think
it's a scam though man
well people were hating on it for from
the beginning because it was how was set
up to just benefit
all of them are founder though all of
cryptocurrencies are set up where
half of the the developers and stuff get
i mean all of them literally all of
cryptocurrencies
nowadays are set up where the founders
get and the developers
yeah because people have figured out
that that's an easy you know get rich
quick scheme
right it's an easy get rich quick scheme
to do that is just give yourself a ton
of crypto then hype it up
exactly so my question is why was
everyone
why what you know here's the thing like
me too like this this gets me in trouble
too is
i like to root for underdogs you know
what i'm saying so
hex is an underdog for sure why is it
not
okay for him to do it and he doesn't
even touch any of that he doesn't touch
any of the coins
he doesn't stake them so when re being
that he doesn't stake them
the community gets more rewards because
if he state them that the community
won't get any rewards so he doesn't
stake them
he doesn't sell them you know say if
anything he just
hasn't so far and it's been in his
interest not to do so
say what he he you said he doesn't do
this he doesn't do that i'm saying it's
not because he can't or won't it's he
just hasn't yet because it's his in his
interest
to basically pump this thing as big as
it can and then as soon as
he sees you know what hey i don't want
to do this forever
uh actually you know what actually this
is kind of dying a little bit let me
just grab my money while i can
and leave everyone else you could man he
could but what i saw but [ __ ] but chris
was against all of those stories so
where's like and my followers
to get paid and then when it pumped up
i was right you know what i'm saying so
i didn't pump something that
dumped on everybody five minutes later
you know what i'm saying i didn't get
paid by hex you know what i'm saying i
saw something that everybody thought
is bad idea which is actually turned out
to be a really really good idea and then
once
i seen how high it was i said all right
i think that's enough i think it might
be time to shut up about this and maybe
walk off with the gains
because i've learned that if you keep on
hyping it hyping it hyping it hyping it
you're gonna be hyping it and it's gonna
fall you know what i'm saying so i've
laid off of the hex content
long time ago i only talk about hex
when people ask about it on live stream
and then when they ask about i'm like oh
what's going on yeah
i mean just me it's like it's like
yeah like i wrote i definitely feel what
you're saying as far as
like being the person who put in uh
protects people and who
vince think who uh you know
right because bitcoin or you you you get
the big connect was a great
investment right up until the time it
crashed i mean that's what
scams are right it's like so you're
saying like oh yeah i was making some
my money for my followers but it's like
you're subjecting them to tremendous
amounts of risk
uh that if they invest too much
you know so and that's why and that's
another thing like if you're it depends
depending on who you're following
they might not tell you hey don't go all
in don't you know what i'm saying they
might say
this is the greatest [ __ ] ever you know
what i'm saying in my first video of hex
i talked about
i'll send it to you i talked about it's
called five reasons why you should
look into hex it didn't say why you
should buy
x it's five reasons why you should look
into hex
you see i'm saying it's stuff it's
little things like that that
change it might change someone's
uh action if i would say five reasons
why you should buy hex
that might make someone go by but no
just look into hex
maybe instead of listening to everybody
calling a scam maybe look into it and do
your
own research you know what i'm saying
and if they did and they bought some
they came up you know so it's
it's it's tough i i'm with you on as far
as like filtering things
but i'm not sure i'm with you as far as
okay it might lose
it might lose momentum he might scam out
i don't think he's gonna do that if
anything i think he's gonna just pinch
away at the liquidity like he's been
doing
um and then you know that might be the
exit but it'll always be there
it's not like a it's not a platform the
worst that he could really do
is you know i mean what is the worst
that he could do the worst thing he
could really do is
just remove all the liquidity and even
if he did that
he could he could take all the ethereum
right
i mean he's already got all the ethereum
nobody he already has the theorem the
theorem on union swap is just is paired
with hex it's not even that much
ethereum it's not even nothing to even
shout about
it's just a couple millions of million
million dollars so the worst thing you
can really do is take that unless it's
like
that so that's a lot the fact that it's
so up it's up so high
it's got a huge community and it's got
the liquidity it's not really
too much that he can that he could do to
hurt it besides you know quitting and
saying all right guys i'm done and it's
just
it'd be up to the community so it's
gonna always be hex it's gonna always be
on ethereum it's gonna always have that
no no i think i think if he if he does
anything wrong everyone immediately
loses
faith in hex and hex dives to zero
because obviously you don't want
any kind of contract you can't and you
don't want any smart contract
well fair enough but you don't want any
smart contract where it's
basically based on the trust of somebody
who has basically signaled to the whole
group that i'm not trustworthy
so if he does anything wrong everybody
that
everybody's who's holding hex is
basically holding a worthless coin
yeah that's true if he doesn't if if
i would say if he gives up i don't know
though man because
it's such a it's such a the whole
decentralized thing is such a new
concept we don't know what'll happen to
somebody
it's something with a community as big
as x like and die hard as those hay
skies are i don't know man
especially it's being as decentralized
i'm just i'm still gonna lean towards
the fact that i don't i don't think it's
i don't think he has bad intentions i
think he is trying to make money but i
don't think he's gonna
do anything malicious that's my final
say okay uh yeah i think uh i think
that's enough of the
uh that's that's the big thing i wanted
to take you to task on but
then i also wanted to ask you what you
think look
let's say you're uh you're you're
looking at the crypto markets
right now you're getting in i don't need
any coin recommendations or anything
like that
but what would you tell somebody
watching these crypto guys because the
reason you reached out is because you
said this guy
asker foalman's onto something all these
people are watching
crypto and they don't know the full
story
and that's what we've heard you talk
about is that like you were talking
about these other influencers
you know the stuff what would you tell
somebody watching crypto news crypto
youtube watching people put out videos
like
three coins to three million dollars
stuff like that like headlines like that
what'd you say uh i mean i'm gonna
i mean to i'm trying not to be cliche
here but
i mean do your own research
um i would say most of the time
like i've been saying most of the time
all coins cryptocurrencies
do not outperform bitcoin
or ethereum over a long term scale the
only one that's done that lately is
ethereum that's
pretty that's outperformed bitcoin over
its entire
um lifespan um
yeah i would say look at their charts
versus well i mean it's a lot of it's a
lot of
layers here if it's if it's a coin
that's been around a lot
look at its chart versus bitcoin and
ethereum
buy things that are low versus bitcoin
and ethereum if you're
and when you buy something it's watching
my files if you buy something
be prepared to hold it for at least two
at least two years
before it's going to be profitable
especially if you're buying something
that's going up
if you buy something when it's low
you're probably going to be profitable a
lot
sooner um as far as youtubers go
um i'm not sure if they're saying hey
this is sponsored
they should be because i think that's
illegal to say that it's not that
it is illegal it is okay so if they're
not saying
then i guess they're just lying but
because they are
so um if a youtuber talks about a
particular coin that you just never
heard before
he probably got paid to talk about it um
don't buy it when he first talks about
it because if you buy
if you buy it when you first talk when
you first talk about it be prepared to
sell it
real soon afterwards are you going to be
holding the bag shortly
um wait so everybody wait till the hype
dies down about it if
everybody's talking about a coin don't
buy it when everybody's talking about it
buy it when everybody shuts up about it
buy it then
you know it's little things like that
that i would a little that's like my
my daily advice i'd like to say every
day you want to you want to buy things
when
nobody cares about it expect that most
things are going to go down
it's probably going to go down in value
so yeah it really does seem like by the
time you've heard about if like
everyone's rushing it everyone's talking
about it you've already missed the boat
yes you're just gonna be one of those
like fools who's left with the the
holding the bag at the end yeah after
everyone's already gotten out it seems
like
it's what it seems like to me um
good okay cool man
so and and don't buy hex
don't buy hex you guys heard it here
first man
uh and and get get out while you can
baby
i mean i this is this is what i'm doing
with hex is i'm not buying anything i'm
just i'm just selling
i stake my hex and then when my stake
ends i sell the interest and i restake
it
you know that's how i'm playing hex i'm
not buying any i haven't bought any hex
in
months so okay interesting
all right uh yeah thanks for coming on
the show
i appreciate you coming on it always
helps to have people
come on the show you know i appreciate
people being willing to talk
being willing to you know face the face
some hard questions
i hope you guys in the crypto community
joined i hope my uh lack of knowledge
didn't
hurt you guys too much i'm i'm watching
you guys now y'all are on my radar
i didn't realize how many shady dealings
were happening at crypto now
uh i have been turned over to it a lot
a lot closer to any youtuber bit boy i
don't have anything against you i know
you're probably gonna watch i don't have
anything i mean
i don't i don't like you know like i
said i don't like the whole
sponsor thing i don't i'm kind of sorry
i kind of called him out a little bit
he's just the first one because he's the
one i had direct experience with
getting wrecked so it's like you guys
cut that [ __ ] out man
stop getting paid to show these coins
just hold the coins
you don't have to be mega rich guys
we're gonna be rich we're holding crypto
regardless you don't have to you don't
have to wreck your followers
make your followers rich man and they'll
you know they'll throw you a party or
something in a couple years
interesting all right thanks man
appreciate you coming on the show
hope you enjoyed this episode of sunday
special we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you